Romantisches Heidelberg:
Hoch über dem Neckar
thront die berühmte Schlossruine
am Hang des Königstuhls,
gut sichtbar von der Alten Brücke.
In der Adventszeit verwandelt sich die
Altstadt in einen riesigen Weihnachtsmarkt.
Beliebt bei Kindern:
die Eisbahn am Karlsplatz.
Aufwärmen können sich Heidelberger
und Touristen mit einem in ganz
Mitteleuropa beliebten Heißgetränk,
dem Glühwein.
Es ist so schön, dieser Duft und der
Geschmack und …, das ist Weihnachten,
Weihnachten im Magen.
Wir mögen dieses Getränk und werden
es sicher wieder probieren.
Am Marktplatz in der Altstadt schenkt
Christoph Schneider seit über 25 Jahren
seinen Glühwein aus.
Wenn gerade kein Kunde da ist, hebt
er den Deckel des Topfes,
lässt Dampf ab und lockt so die
Leute an.
Um 17 Uhr kommen dann die Leute
nach der Arbeit,
und dann ist hier Trubel
und viel Spaß angesagt.
Besonders stolz ist Christoph Schneider
auf seinen neuen Merlot-Glühwein.
Der ist weniger süß als die
herkömmlichen Glühweine.
Unsere Gäste, die sagen, selbst wenn
ma (wir) drei getrunken haben oder vier,
kein Kopf am nächsten Tag.
Und von diesen Weinbergen kommen
die Trauben für den Glühwein.
Das Weingut Adam Müller in Leimen
liegt circa 20 Autominuten
von Heidelberg entfernt.
Winzer Matthias Müller bringt Glühwein
nicht nur klassisch in Rot,
sondern auch in Weiß und sogar Pink
auf den Markt.
Ganz traditionell ist der Glühwein aus
Rotwein gemacht,
so auch bei uns hier im Hause.
In den letzten Jahren verspüren wir
eine verstärkte Nachfrage nach Weißwein.
Weißwein daher, da er weniger
Gerbstoffe hat, leichter ist,
fruchtbetonter ist.
Und infolgedessen war auch
der Kundenwunsch einfach
nach einem weißen Glühwein.
In Heidelberg haben wir eine dritte
Variante, einen Rosé-Glühwein.
Anlass ist der „Pink Monday“,
eine Benefizveranstaltung zugunsten
der Aidshilfe.
Wie entsteht der spezielle Geschmack
des Glühweins?
Nathalie Müller, die mit ihrem Mann
zusammenarbeitet,
lüftet ein Familiengeheimnis.
Das Rezept, nach dem wir heute
noch arbeiten, ist ein ganz schlichtes,
altes Rezept unserer Uroma Greta.
Was die Zutaten angeht, beschränken
wir uns auf drei Gewürze,
Nelke, Stern-Anis, Zimt
und beim Obst sind es ganz klassisch
Zitrone und Orange.
Zurück in Heidelberg.
Der Glühwein passt auch gut zu
deftigen Leckereien
wie Reibekuchen und Pilzen.
Glühweinstände gibt es hier viele.
Der Weingenuss gehöre eben
zum Lebensgefühl der Heidelberger,
sagt man in der Region.
Mir ist ganz warm und das hält mich
auch warm, ja.
Es ist auch grad mein erster Glühwein
dieses Jahr, und erst mal der Geruch,
der dann in die Nase halt kommt durch
den ganzen Körper durch.
Es gibt mir dieses Gefühl, angekommen
zu sein.
Sind wir ehrlich, eigentlich macht nur
der Glühwein
den Geruch aus vom Weihnachtsmarkt und
nicht der Lebkuchen, deswegen Glühwein.
Heidelberg, eine Stadt, in der man für
die kalte Jahreszeit
bestens gewappnet ist.